I'm a good note we have a grandmaster
Christian Trillo with a Maurice to talk
about a really exciting program taking
place at Mizzou over to you Maurice well
not just is the program taking place but
this guy is gonna be the boss of it
christian grandmaster christian
guerrilla from romania a top player
himself recently one women joined the
u.s. national open the national open and
I think you work once in a while here at
the club right absolutely take my place
when I'm off gallivanting somewhere in
the world yeah good to have you on the
show and first of all congratulations
thank you very much tell us about this
program at Mizzou so it came naturally
it was an idea that sprung into my mind
maybe four years ago after I graduated
college myself at one of the chest
universities UT Dallas and I I wanted
the big program I wanted the big school
because I felt I missed something at UT
Dallas from the college experience the
American College experience so you know
a lot of a lot of universities came to
mind but you know Mizzou was one of them
I I pitched the idea to the right people
aka Rex Sinquefield who is the men that
made made it happen you know he reached
the right people and then it just came
about but it's a natural progression
because in Missouri Trust is huge yeah
you have the same blues Chess Club you
have the st. Louis University you have
Webster they're all competing for for
something big and and collegiate chess
is booming it only made sense that the
largest universities in Missouri would
pick it up tell me you do have that
competition you got Webster you've got
Webster with Susan Polgar
you've got flu with Alejandro Ramirez
and you and Alejandro work partners
absolutely as being seconds to Fabiano
Caruana so is there little bit of trash
talking going on who school's gonna
recruit the top players for the way
absolutely absolutely and jokingly we
were saying that you we want Fabiano
on our team you know and we were
pitching where to go you come to me no
no
this flu you know and all this type of
trash-talking but material but of course
I mean it's all in a good good fun and
where are you gonna be recruiting these
students from internationally as well as
nationally so I'm looking everywhere you
know again the recruiting competition is
fierce they have a heads up on on the
program but at the same time you know
there's a lot of very strong players out
there that are looking hopefully to
combine academics with chess and I think
you know it's it's a huge opportunity
for them to come to the United States to
join this chess boom that is happening
in Missouri and you know I I hope to
facilitate that speak to that the
combination of academics and chess
because you want a fabulous chess team
obviously on but these youngsters are
gonna be coming for their degrees and no
ears maybe beyond chess what how do you
convince them that Mizzou is the place
to come say absolutely no and and you
know you have Mizzou which is extremely
extremely prestigious on various degrees
you have a Business School you have law
school you have Medical School one of
the very few universities that has all
three and of course you have it's a d1
school so there were athletic programs
are just dominating across the nation so
you know it's it's a very demanding
university academically as well as
competitive when it comes to athletics
and I think I'm going to try to
replicate that with with the Chess Club
I'm going try to combine both their
academics with playing chess and then
furthering that they're just career now
I read a note about the club partnering
with the University of Missouri as well
yeah how is that partnership going to
work well the club through their
financial support you know they they
helped bring this program to life and
it's you know there's going there's a
lot of potential partnerships going on
in the future you know we we were
looking at Mizzou to promote chess as a
whole in the nation and hopefully we're
going to have some
international students coming and
competing in those tournaments maybe
some national collegiate tournaments as
well you know I feel there's there's a
lot of potential in college chess you
know right now you have you have the
Penn Americans you have the Final Four
and then you have the first edition I
think of the rapid and blitz the
collegiate wrapping and blitz which is
going to happen at SLU this year really
exactly it's happening in a couple of
weeks actually Wow
things are developing there's a lot of
ideas in mind and I hope Mizzou is going
to be at the center of those ideas now
they're gonna be students who are
interested in finding out more about
this program
what kind of scholarships are we talking
about free ride to the University yeah
yeah free ride very competitive
scholarships so you know the invitations
for this year have been sent and
hopefully we're going to hear back from
from from those guys but as we move
along I'm hoping this is going to be a
tiered scholarship program and everybody
will be able to join of course the Grand
Master's and very strong players will
get the full ride but I want it to be an
opportunity for our players of all all
categories fantastic congratulations on
this leadership and I'm curious to see
what kind of players will come to Mizzou
and start trash-talking you right say
coach
hopefully they will be able to beat me
you know those type of players I'm
looking for question for you before
Maurice lets you go you know I'm such a
fan of what's happening at Mizzou
because I really love and I think you're
the perfect pick to lead up this program
because you're a grandmaster you're
super into fitness so that ties in with
a sports angle and I also personally
love academia so I think this is just a
wonderful tree ad but I got to ask any
plans to recruit specifically to women
players because here at the Karen's Cup
we you know we need to encourage this
game among women at the professional
level the child level and then also the
collegiate level
no absolutely or in the future I'm
definitely looking to
having an old female team and also I
mean the the application process is
going to be open again this year we the
invitation some of them are already out
there but at the same time I can be
refused and then other spots will be
open I will reach out to other people
potentially but of course yes we do want
an old female team as we progress
through the years yes yes but I cannot I
cannot give you anything nothing you
signed yet you know this these students
have to pass through some tests you know
the application progress and and it's
it's not done yet it's not it's not done
deal but it's a verbal commitment so but
you will let us know as soon as there so
absolutely absolutely we want to know
first
yeah for sure Christian cruller
grandmaster and now the head of the
university of missouri program here in
st. louis collegiate chess starting